hey guys I'm Ryan right so today I'm
gonna be checking out the trailer for
why don't you know it
another Paranormal Activity movie the
ghost dimension official trailer number
one all right let's do this let's see if
it's a piece of [ __ ] or not where'd you
get this from a box like any VHS tapes
in the basement just never seeing
something and there's this thing I'm
picking up the camera who is that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for us to be in this house this is no
coincidence
I believe she's part of the prophecy
[Music]
like there's a bomb
[Music]
three that's just what we need okay well
looks alright I mean the people were
sending this to me being like this looks
like a piece of [ __ ] but I didn't really
find it to be that shitty it doesn't
look original okay first off trailer
showed a little too much this is a
horror film you don't want to show
everything you want to be scared
it's like marketing sells tickets sure
but good word-of-mouth does too if you
[ __ ] leave some surprises open this
one seems to amp up the supernatural
factor a little bit more you know like
one thing I liked about the paranormal
films is that you couldn't really see
the ghosts you know sometimes you got
like little glimpses of something but
you never really quite saw the demon or
whatever it was that was [ __ ] with
the family or those Mexican kids I wish
they saved that just for the movie they
show you a lot of like that weird
demonic shadow thing appearing and it
doesn't look that scary the movie
doesn't look that scary the first minute
of this trailer I was like that's kind
of creepy when he's looking at the
footage of the two little girls and then
he's answering them so it's like a
dimension and also speaking at the
beginning I love how they say these
tapes are from 20 years ago but the
quality is amazing something tells me
because this paranormal that everyone's
gonna die but the girl cuz she's part of
the prophecy and like the main
characters seem a little stupid yeah
this movie doesn't look the greatest
main characters seem a little dumb we
got this special camera that could see
more than a regular camera so let's use
hit its conjure up some demons and
ghosts the whole bringing the priest and
thing I am so sick of that from every
horror film you know priests clearly are
not that great at their job when it
comes to exercising these demons so stop
bringing in the priests like it looks
like it's trying to be more like
insidious and sinister in a way but I
don't know like the first paranormal
movie yeah I know a lot of people hated
on it but a lot of people were scared
shitless of it and so was i I went into
the first one not knowing any
about the movie never seen a trailer or
a clip nothing so it scared the crap out
of me the second one I'm a lot of people
who don't like but I thought it was
scary too third one was a blast after
that they are hmm
mark ones was a little bit upper more
but most wait you know these movies are
not turning out the greatest I like how
they're trying to do something a little
bit more fresh like it doesn't look at
like an exact replica of the other ones
I don't know well worked so well for
paranormal was the fact that it you
didn't see a lot of stuff and that it
was spooky and a lot was left to the
imagination this one I feel like they're
showing you everything instead of
leaving it to the imagination and
seriously they should just change the
[ __ ] characters you know it's it's
cool and all but other you know linking
it to the same characters throughout the
movies but come on how many people are
gonna document their experiences it's
like part of this demonic prophecy is
that people have to get it on camera I
mean don't get me wrong stuff about it
looks cool like I said I like how
they're trying to add some fresh stuff
to it for all I know actually seeing
more of the monsters or whatever the
[ __ ] you want to call them see more of
that might make this film even more
interesting because we're so used to not
seeing them that it might actually work
I think creepy little girls are always
creepy they creep me out consistently
and women too in general just freak me
out they're they're totally separate
race yeah I'll probably end up checking
it out I've seen every single one of
them and yeah I'll probably still be
there and everyone's still gonna watch
this [ __ ] movie anyway guys thanks
for tuning in if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter and vine where if we
get enough followers we can get more
product placement that's right already
been reeling in some extra cash spending
it on the strippers male strippers for
my girlfriend she won't let me see
female strippers
Brandon Swofford hey Ryan and Friends I
love your channel and reaction videos
your jokes and facial expressions are
always priceless the girls in your
videos are beautiful - damn right they
are you should react to one of my videos
I would love to see what you think so
you should go ahead and check out B
money rules he looks like he has an
interesting channel I'll be taking a
look at it soon but Brandon Swafford in
the meantime my friend you should focus
on B money rules as much as possible if
there's one thing I've learned from
living in America is that money is the
root of all happiness money is beautiful
greed is good Gordon Gekko Jordan
Belfort wolf of Wall Street these are
people who are truly happy because being
rich just allows you to buy as much crap
as you want like if you're feeling
lonely and depressed on the inside if
you're rich you can just buy stuff and
block all that out of the way be many
rules liking them